welcome everybody hope you had a good
weekend a lot of different things going
on and i want to jump right into it you
know one of the things that was good
last week that happened on the one year
anniversary of the january 6 trump riots
was that at least in some circles
there was a message which we heard
multiple times which is okay it's been a
year
and a year ago it didn't work the
insurrection failed the attempt at a
coup
failed to actually keep the guy who
didn't win in power
but instead of saying great it failed we
don't need to think about it anymore
many prominent voices have been saying
the coup attempt continues they're going
to go crazy in 2024 trying to do it
again and they may even try it to some
degree in 2022 and unless we're prepared
it has been made clear
that were they slightly less incompetent
they might have pulled it off still
unlikely they truly would have pulled it
off but
the major and basic systems of democracy
that we in some sense take for granted
could have failed us and there are a
bunch of different pieces that i want to
mention to you today that have been
published which i think are really
really good and step back for a second
and think about from how many different
areas we are hearing this
former military generals former u.s
presidents
some of the most quoted thinkers of our
time like noam chomsky and on and on and
on so let's just jump right in and take
a look now last week we already looked
at this first example
retired general warns the u.s military
could back a coup after the 2024
election i i have an entire clip on this
on the youtube channel so i won't redo
it but the gist of this was that
actually three retired generals are
warning
that if in 2024 we saw
another desire
and another attempt for republicans to
take an election that they did not win
if
they had the support
of the upper echelon of the military if
the upper echelon of the military
believed
that the person that won didn't actually
win and decided to help the
insurrectionists the outcome could be
completely different in other words that
the coup could succeed
if the insurrectionists had the upper
echelon of the military on their side we
talked about that last week also last
week
we started we we are starting to see
concern in canada our friendly neighbors
to the north of if the u.s is no longer
democratic what does that mean for us
how do we need to protect ourselves and
i told you about this report and article
from the canadian political science
professor thomas homer dixon who is
saying we in canada this is not even a
warning to americans this is thomas
homer dixon warning his own country and
saying
we could have a right-wing dictatorship
in the united states by 2030. depending
on what happens in 22 and in 24 and
theoretically subsequently in 2028
with a continued erosion
of
a continued growth of this authoritarian
right-wing movement
bolstered to some degree by the way by
some left-wingers looking away and
saying there's nothing to see here
that's also part of the problem but
mostly the people doing it are the
problem
the u.s could be a right-wing
dictatorship by 2030 but there are more
concerns and i think it's great that
this is being published from different
voices
because it is so important to understand
jimmy carter wrote a really good piece
last week on the eve of the january 6
trump riot anniversary in the new york
times called i fear for our democracy
and
this is part of a number of essays that
were published and it's very very much
worth reading
but in it jimmy carter says one year on
promoters of the lie that the election
was stolen have taken over one political
party and stoked distrust in our
electoral systems these forces exert
power and influence through relentless
disinformation which continues to turn
americans against americans according to
the survey center on american life 36
percent of americans agree that the
traditional american way of life is
disappearing so fast that we may have to
use force to save it the washington post
recently reported roughly 40 percent of
republicans believe violent action
against the government is sometimes
justified
and in this
in this jimmy carter says they seek to
win by any means and many americans are
being persuaded to think and act
likewise threatening to collapse the
foundations of our security and
democracy with breathtaking speed i now
fear that what we have fought so hard to
achieve globally
the right to free fair elections
unhindered by strongmen politicians who
seek nothing more than to grow their own
power has become dangerously fragile at
home good for jimmy carter noam chomsky
noam chomsky says the republican soft
coup is still underway
one year after the capital assault and
this includes transcripts of an
interview uh
with um with chomsky where he says
participants in the assault on the
capital doubtless had varying
perceptions and motives but were united
in the effort to overthrow an elected
government in short an attempted coup by
definition
it was furthermore an attempt that could
have succeeded if a few prominent
republican figures had changed their
stance and gone along with the coup
attempt and if the military command had
made different decisions chomsky
referencing what the retired generals
say if you get the military the outcome
can be different trump was making every
effort to facilitate the coup which
would surely have been applauded by a
large majority of republican voters and
by the republican political leadership
with which with few exceptions grovels
at his feet in a shameful display of
cowardice implications for the future
are all too clear the republican
organization is carefully laying the
groundwork for success next time
whatever the electoral outcome might be
this is
very very serious and lastly
jim chrisinger with a good piece opinion
what authoritarianism would look like in
america where he writes
many americans don't fear a potential
slide into authoritarianism because they
have no basis for doing so our oceans
and hegemony have coddled us we take
democracy for granted but democracy and
the rule of law are not the normal state
of governments certainly not
historically pointing out
authoritarianism wouldn't happen
overnight
but authoritarian regimes have shown us
a road map if trump and his enablers get
their way how you experience your life
would depend on whether you identified
and were identified as a trump
republican
identified as a trump republican with
your bumper sticker you'd be more likely
to get a warning instead of a speeding
ticket you'd gain the inside track for
government jobs grants and permits
decisions about government benefits like
unemployment and disability would be
more likely to go your way your children
would be more likely to win scholarships
and admission to their chosen schools
you'd get more favorable loan and
mortgage treatment better access to
scarce goods the best tickets
regulations would be interpreted in your
favor or maybe just ignored you could
rely on the criminal justice and
judicial systems to go easy on you if
not help you out this is a very very
much worth reading article
and there are a lot of people already
saying the 2024 election is going to be
bonkers nuts you were going to see them
put up claims of fraud just like they
did in 2020 but they may have
secretaries of state election
administrators actually willing to do
the flip remember in georgia brad
raffensberger said we're not going to do
that we're not going to do that
they may actually lay the groundwork
where they do have secretaries of state
willing to play ball and i don't think
we're gonna have to wait until 2024 to
see it i believe the midterms are going
to show us where we are headed and how
quickly and so there's a lot of people
in the right-wing media who dismiss
january 6th because it failed
and you would better believe that if
they had succeeded
and trump was still president some of
those very people saying it wasn't
really anything because it failed would
be praising it
as a victory for the real winner so
those people you can't listen to they
don't care about democracy they're
against it if democracy leads to an
outcome they don't want it's not been a
priority of the republican party for a
really long time and unfortunately there
is now a whole series of clones of
donald trump that are out there in
congress and running for office in 2022
and no doubt in 2024 so good for all of
these people continuing to point out
this is not over it's not they tried it
once and it failed and now we move on
they're going to try it again
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video